to be honest most kids don't like school
they don't my little brother hates
school because all they're doing is
being prepared to go to work for eight
hours a day what you were saying about
like the amount of energy
um obviously Like a Stranger teacher or
whatever you want to call it is putting
into the child when I was in school
there was always like one or two moments
maybe like once every Academic Year
someone would call the teacher mum I
don't think that's an accident because
there's someone there's someone in front
of them you know for however many hours
a day like it might be a silly point but
I don't know
I've done
that okay if you have a question you ask
them you're awesome can I go to the
toilet you talk to them in a way that
you would a parent and then like you get
these kids off put their hand up mum and
then everyone lost but it's like I don't
think that's an accident I think that's
you know I feel like the schooling
system I agree they won't they want you
to see these people